e aí
a todos nós temos histórias vividas para
contar felizes ou tristes e cada
história importa a sua história importa
a minha começou em montes claros norte
de minas filha de pais cuidado mais
avançada num contexto de alcoolismo de
ambas as partes
é de um lado minha mãe brasileira
socióloga professora com o primeiro
casamento e dois filhos do outro meu pai
e o gustavo
o e os lábios sobrevivente da segunda
guerra mundial com o primeiro casamento
e três filhas do segundo casamento dos
dois eu sou filha única
hoje eu me considero uma sobrevivente do
caos você sabe onde é a calça
o caos segundo a mitologia grega era
considerado o deus primordial do
universo de acordo com o poeta grego
hesíodo causa era tudo aquilo que era
desordem tesão quebra separação
desequilíbrio enquanto eros o seu filho
era tudo aquilo que era união tudo
aquilo que era equilíbrio mas assim como
eros era filho do caos o equilíbrio ele
nasce do desequilíbrio
e durante muitos anos eu vivi nesse
contexto de alcoolismo dentro da minha
casa e foram anos né com bastante
ausências muitas situações difíceis para
ser vivenciadas cotidianamente teve
situações de violência doméstica teve um
abuso sexual por parte de um funcionário
da minha família
e teve muita vergonha dos vizinhos dos
amigos teve noites dormidas na praça eu
e minha mãe
e enfim tivemos uma uma vida que vocês
podem imaginar um pouco difícil dentro
desse contexto e um pensamento que
sempre vinha na minha cabeça quando eu
dormia era porque eu por que que eu
nasci na sua família
a e vocês podem imaginar a quantidade de
coisas que ao longo de tantos anos
vivendo uma rotina de alcoolismo dentro
da minha casa quantas coisas foram
suprimidas reprimida se da minha
infância apesar de para muitos eu ter
tido uma infância perfeita porque aos
olhos dos outros que não estão dentro de
casa a história muito diferente né e eu
sou muito grata aos meus amigos que
durante muitos anos pessoas próximas
queridas fizeram com que a minha vida
literalmente fosse uma vida bela
e me fizeram entrar no mundo do
faz-de-conta da imaginação e realmente
abstrair toda aquela história
a gratidão
e durante todos estes anos
principalmente depois da minha
adolescência eu acabei desenvolvendo um
quadro de obesidade devido a um quadro
de compulsão alimentar que mais tarde
depois de mais amadurecimento eu entendi
tem associação com o abuso
e durante muito tempo eu não tinha
condição de entender aquela história foi
preciso muito amadurecimento nesse
percurso
e por muitos por muito tempo eu tive
vergonha de ser filho de pais mais
velhos eu tive vergonha de ser filho de
pais alcoólatras
bom e lá para os por volta dos meus 16
anos eu decidi o que eu precisava fazer
alguma coisa
eu já tinha muito tempo que estava
acontecendo e algo dentro de mim
precisava fazer alguma coisa foi aí que
eu liguei para o alcoólicos anônimos
e eles foram lá em casa fizeram um
convite um tempo depois meus pais
pararam de beber os 21
e foi necessário muita coragem muita fé
muita resiliência
e eu precisava levar ajuda para minha
família de alguma maneira e eu vivenciei
essas palavras tem nem saber o que
realmente ela significava vão naquela
história naquele momento
e lá para os meus 19 anos quando eu
percebi que enfim eu podia respirar um
pouco abaixar a guarda eu tive um quadro
de depressão e eu tentei suicídio
é mas eu posso dizer com propriedade que
eu não queria deixar de viver
e eu queria na verdade parar de sofrer
eu queria na verdade esquecer tudo
aquilo que aconteceu toda aquela
história doída e tantos dias que tiraram
de mim coisas muito preciosas da minha
infância
o mar quando a gente está naquele fundo
do poço é muito difícil a gente ser
acolhido é muito difícil quem é que já
teve uma depressão ou tem alguém próximo
que passou por isso sabe o quanto é
difícil acolher alguém com esse
adoecimento
e é preciso a gente enxergar um pontinho
de luz no fundo do poço no fim do túnel
o porquê
e é preciso resistir é preciso acreditar
que realmente algo vai dar certo
e foi preciso muita ajuda a profissional
muita ajuda da minha família que também
foi muito acolhedora nesse momento e
muita ajuda de amigos para eu conseguir
superar esse quadro de depressão
ah mas nem que esteja um pontinho é
preciso a gente se apegar a ele porque
pode parecer impossível nesse momento
mas é possível é preciso a gente não
desistir de nós mesmos primeiramente é
preciso a gente transcender é preciso a
gente acreditar é preciso a gente
superar eu fui percebendo que aos poucos
era possível florir em meio a todo esse
caos e
e para que as flores e os frutos
apareçam é necessário a gente resistir é
necessário
o e durante todo esse tempo eu digo que
hoje ainda é muito importante a jornada
do autoconhecimento e durante todo esse
tempo isso também foi muito importante
foram muitos anos de terapia foram
muitos anos olhando para dentro de mim
mesmo para conseguir superar traumas e
consegui superar dores e conseguir
superar tantas coisas que dentro de mim
precisavam acontecer foi precisa eu
entender eu aceitar eu perdoar
re-significar e transformar essa
realidade
o a superação ela só vem através do
perdão
oi e para perdoar é preciso conhecer
para perdoar é preciso se conhecer e
conhecer a história do outro eu precisei
mergulhar muito profundo em quem eu sou
em quem são os meus pais
a conhecer toda a nossa história de onde
eles vieram tudo que eles passarão
também na vida tudo que também foi
tirado deles para entender também quem
era eu onde eu estava e por que que eu
estava realmente naquele lugar
é isso sempre pode parecer impossível em
muitos momentos mas é possível tem 11
anos que eu moro em belo horizonte e
essa cidade me acolheu foi onde minha
vida realmente recomeçou
o e logo que eu mudei eu achei que tava
tudo bem que tava tudo ótimo vida nova
eu passei em terapia ocupacional na ufmg
a minha linda profissão que exerço hoje
e eu achei que estava tudo bem mas teve
mais um pouco de caos nessa história
toda
e no início da minha faculdade minha mãe
teve um avc meu pai é um contou uma
perna e meu cunhado faleceu tudo no
mesmo ano tudo de uma vez eu precisei
voltar para montes claros minha cidade
natal e eu achei por um momento que
estava tudo perdido de novo foi um
momento de recaída eu achei que eu não
ia conseguir retomar
é mas eu retomei eu voltei para belo
horizonte eu me formei eu casei eu tive
meu filho bernardo
ah e tudo isso todo esse processo
inclusive a minha própria faculdade foi
me dando um sentimento de que era
possível realmente transformar tudo isso
que eu vivi
e eu fui fechando um ciclo para iniciar
outro e nessa história toda eu fui
percebendo que eu podia cuidar novamente
assim como eu tive que cuidar por muito
tempo dos meus pais em muitos momentos
por mais que eles não percebesse que eu
fazia isso
esse é um sentimento que brotava
naturalmente eu fui percebendo que esse
ciclo estava se fechando para iniciar o
outro cuidado essa sou eu grávida do
bernardo e eu fui percebendo que essa
era minha grande missão de vida cuidar
eu nasci para isso e toda a nossa
história a minha história a sua história
ela importa mas ela não nos define
e se ela tivesse me definido eu não tava
aqui hoje falando para vocês eu nunca
imaginei que eu precisaria neste palco
aqui para contar isso para vocês
e esse é meu filho
bom e quando me perguntam como que eu
escolhi trabalhar com longevidade que é
isso que eu faço hoje eu trabalho com
idosos e
e eu respondo que eu já nasci isso
e eu nasci nesse contexto a minha vida
fez
em toda toda a volta que eu tive na vida
tudo foi envolvido com longevidade e aos
poucos eu fui percebendo que seu era
é tão boa nisso porque não fazer disso a
minha grande missão de vida
e é preciso auto-responsabilidade para
superar trauma é preciso a gente não ter
dó de nós mesmos não é sobre door não é
sobre culpa mas é sobre lutar
incansavelmente pela vida é sobre a
gente acreditar que vai haver um lugar
melhor para gente é sobre evoluir é
sobre ter auto cuidado auto respeito
já teve muito amor na minha história
meus pais me amarão incondicionalmente
mesmo diante de tantas coisas
acontecidas
ah e hoje eu posso dizer de coração
aberto e feliz que eu tenho muito
orgulho de ser filha da dona gislene e
do meu pai que faleceu há 4 meses e que
era para tá aqui hoje ouvindo essa
história também pela primeira vez eu
tenho muito orgulho de ser filha deles
porque eu sou fruto disso a minha
história não seria diferente eu não
seria quem eu sou se eu não fosse filha
deles então te amo mãe te amo pai
obrigada
e eles poucos eu fui entendendo o que é
preciso quatro pilares para uma vida com
sentido
e é preciso a gente ter pertencimento é
preciso a gente entender e conhecer de
onde a gente veio e tomar posse disso é
preciso a gente ter propósito é preciso
a gente entender porquê
é porque eu estou fazendo isso
a transcendência porque nós precisamos
enxergar a situação de uma forma mais
ampla para que a gente realmente consiga
ver a realidade e transformá-la e
contação de história porque só eu posso
contar a minha história apesar de tantas
pessoas envolvidas nela só eu posso
contar a minha história
e aí
e eu nasci para cuidar
e hoje se eu não conseguir unir o meu
trabalho a minha história quem eu sou
nada para mim vai fazer sentido
e quando minha mãe insistentemente me
fala assim porque que você não tentou um
concurso
e eu brinco com ela eu não nasci para
isso mãe então a gente encontra um
caminho para a gente ser feliz e isso é
o único né esse é o nosso propósito
o e eu encontrei na longevidade o meu
ikigai você sabe ok que gás é uma
palavra japonesa que traduza a razão de
ser é aquilo que faz o nosso olho
brilhar é aquilo que faz a gente acordar
de manhã e tem uma razão de existir e
foi aí que eu fundei o motivado e holden
meus dois projetos do coração que tem
como premissa criar soluções para os 60
mais viverem melhor eu sou apaixonada em
trabalhar com idosos
e floresçam em meio ao caos e
é reconhecida que aquilo que você fez
faz parte da sua história mas isso não
te define e se não te define você pode
ressignificar
olá eu sou bom em cuidar eu usarei isso
então ao meu favor
e eu não posso ignorar esse fato às
vezes está na nossa cara aquilo que a
gente nasceu para fazer e a gente não
enxerga
se transforme a dor em perdão
e para ter superação e vencer é preciso
perdoar perdoar de coração e para
perdoar é preciso conhecer e conhecer
você escolhe história de amor ou de dor
e viva por você por suas escolhas e não
pelos outros não pelos seus pais
e descubra seu próprio caminho a
expectativa do outro não é sua
e é preciso sair da ilha para enxergar a
ilha óleo de fora como se o mundo
estivesse em suas mãos
e a mudança real ela é de dentro para
fora nós precisamos ter alto
responsáveis a vida ela não é linear mas
elas têm nos levar a algum lugar
e eu encontrei o meu lugar no mundo
oi qual é o seu lugar no mundo
a gratidão é